sion au chapitre politique est au plus
haut niveau de l'état les réactions de
lionel jospin dès ce matin qui
soulignait que le gouvernement avait
respecté le droit c'était son devoir
pour sa part le président de la
république il ya quelques instants
évoqué le retour à une situation de
droit je vous propose de les écouter
maurice papon a été remis cet après midi
aux autorités françaises je tiens à
remercier les autorités suisses pour
leur décision et pour leur coopération
ainsi force reste à la loi et les
décisions de la justice française
pourront être respectée je voudrais
remercier du fond du coeur les autorités
suisses que nous avons informé la
présence sur leur territoire de monsieur
papon nous avons fait preuve ce
gouvernement d'un respect absolu du
droit
et aussi je pense d'une grande
efficacité et ses deux choses doivent
aller ensemble
il faut le comprendre les démocraties
utilise certains moyens mais elles ne
sont en rien un puissante quand elles
ont une volonté